[Music]
and so it comes to pass I guess we're
starting ages after the twin vessels
were forged a New Soul appears
brave soul
S one day you will stand before two
baboons
[Music]
one day you will rent the very fabric
that binds this land
but until that day comes
you must toot
judge your trombone brave soul and you
may yet become the trombone chap
what the [__] was that hi welcome to
trombone champ I don't know what that
was I wanted to play a trombone and not
conquer the destiny of the baboons what
is baboon
what
is this
I don't know what that's about
um why does this remind me of do you
guys ever remember God of uh not God of
War you remember this obscure game no
black and white it was a game where you
had you were a God and you were had
people and inside your tent looks like
the inside of the temple Elixir put up a
reference but I don't know if anybody's
gonna get it it was a while ago anyway
I'm here to play Trombone so I played
trumpet when I was in school
jubilin the studious
[Music]
what the frick is this why is there none
that looked like me I'm not saying
literally but there are none that look
like me not even remotely and there's no
option to make one did they think they
covered all the bases
because they didn't
um it's studious case aisle all right
brass I I had a lacquered trumpet which
I'm not saying is a good one I don't
know I had a lacquered strat of air it's
so loud a lacquered Stradivarius all
right let's start with a warm-up
now here's the thing I do all of my
thumbnails in Photoshop with my mouth
[Music]
not with my mouth my mouse you play
Trombone with your mouth you play
trumpet with your mouth I use my mouse
for pretty much everything I've never
really been a stylist person I know some
people do play this with a stylisher I'm
guessing that I don't actually know that
for a fact but oftentimes I say things
with confidence that it sounds like a
fact but it doesn't necessarily mean
that it's true however it is true that I
use my mouse for pretty much anything
now I don't know if that means I'm gonna
be good keyboard may be easier on your
wrist maybe you got weak ass wrists and
maybe you're a bit of a [__] if you
play well you build combos increase your
champ meter they say you get big points
watch the breath meter if you hold on to
a no for too long you'll run out of
breath get better lungs stupid weakling
bastard
have fun
you can't guarantee that I'll do that
as the developer of the game that's up
to Why is it inverted
holy crap what is wrong with you what
kind of demon would play a trombone
inverted is that what the developers
think that people want is that with the
developers of this game are all about
are they a bunch of inverted controls
baboon quantity
[Music]
I don't like baboons
oh oh excuse me
oh I'm sorry oh I'm sorry are you
telling me that
this is not in this is normal because it
says right now oh and wait sorry my bad
I was getting angry over nothing there
we go normal all right anyway now let's
get to the game hey what we're here for
is um some lovely Blues
okay
[Music]
oh and I'm warm now and I'm warm and
warming up warming up warming up
wow
I'm warming up and I'm wondering
[Music]
God he's taking me back to Band days
oh God
warm warm warm warm warm
warm warm warm warm warm warm warm warm
more more more warm
and meh screw
[Applause]
wow
wow I own what baboon
[Music]
I don't understand what the baboon's
about well it's pretty fun
um I'm trying normal trombone
ball game
sailor's hornpipe
[Music]
just give it a try here how hard could
it be
there are between two and four spiders
living inside the average trombone
[Music]
oh God
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
my God yes
[Music]
[Applause]
God I'm a good dumb boner yes yes yes
yes yes
that was only my second tromboning ever
done what do you think about that
everybody else everyone else who's
played this game before before me suck
an egg you couldn't have done as good as
I did ever if you even tried who do you
think you are not me I boned before and
you'll never bone
I don't know that was good [__] that I
know that it was good it was amazing I'm
incredible I love myself what's my graph
look like look at that [__]
all right let's try something else it
was all I learned a lot in that one
Flight of the Bumblebees okay okay so
this one now they say that this didn't
have a lot of slides I gotta say it did
have a lot of slides man of Tokyo has a
lot of Fury and more slides bumblebee
has lots of slides
I have a lot of bumblebees
I don't believe that
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus Christ
you ever just go blind I think I just
went blind for a little bit there
then we're joking about this having more
slides
if anything I think they underestimate
just how many slides that we're gonna be
because they're all slides
nailed it I think I did something there
how many points did I even get I wasn't
paying attention
hey what does my graph look like yeah it
looks like bumblebees
give me something with less slides all
right here we go whatever this is
marcelaine
ah
[Music]
I
[Applause]
[Music]
think this is French
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean honestly I it said it was gonna
be like hi yes
yes
that's what I'm talking about here comes
the Mountain King
I don't think that's true either
[Music]
oh God
oh cowards I could have done it
[Music]
that's what it should be
[Applause]
yeah we change your own game [__]
[Music]
foreign
I am the greatest trombone player that
ever existed don't pay attention to the
score because I did amazingly that's
what is all about this game is silly you
know when it comes down to Mouse based
games that require a lot of fine control
why not fire a power wash simulator is
it uncouth of me to fire up another game
in the middle of me playing
holy crap look at this gigantic okay
good
why
God is huge anyway it's not the first
time that I've said that oh you're
kidding me
they get only 400 bucks for this one
look how massive it is
jeez at least it's all one flat surface
and you don't have to go up on top maybe
that's the Saving Grace of it oh never
mind you know what I'm saying I'd rather
be playing trombone champ than do this
one oh but if I started I'm gonna have
to finish it
oh how tough is it
oh no it's gonna be tough God
uh lyxian put in trombone sounds for
when I'm doing this
[Music]
power simulator trombone mod
can I can you mod my power washer to
look like a trombone looks and you could
do that right good good good just just
go ahead and do that just go ahead and
do that nah it's easy no don't worry
about just make it to trombone it's
making a trombone just make it a
trombone just make it a trombone
did you make me a trombone
am I a trombone right now
well thanks for watching I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna do something
about this
bye-bye